ROADBLOCKS CHINA IS PLACING ON
INVESTIGATIONS INTO THE ORIGINS
OF THE PANDEMIC.
HOUSE LAWMAKERS GETTING READY
TO INTRODUCE TWO BIPARTISAN
BILLS AIMED AT CHINA TODAY.
ONE OF THEM WOULD ALLOW
VICTIMS’ FAMILIES TO SUE
BEIJING OVER THE COVID OUTBREAK.
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR NEWT
GINGRICH, FORMER SPEAKER OF THE
HOUSE.
GOOD MORNING TO YOU.
VERY CURIOUS TO GET YOUR
ANALYSIS OF HOW YOU SEE THIS
PLAYING OUT.
LET’S BEGIN THERE AND THEN I’LL
PICK UP WITH A FEW THINGS AFTER
THAT.
WHERE IS IT GOING?
>> LOOK, WE’RE IN A PERIOD
WHERE YOU HAVE COMMON SENSE AND
TECHNICALITIES.
COMMON SENSE IS THIS WAS A
MANUFACTURED VIRUS.
IT ALMOST CERTAINLY CAME OUT OF
WUHAN.
THE BURDEN OUGHT TO BE ON CHINA.
THE CHINESE HAVE LIED TO THE
WORLD HEALTH ORGANIZATION,
THEY’VE LIED TO THE PLANET.
THEY’VE NOW CLOSED DOWN THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE ANY KIND OF
SERIOUS INVESTIGATION.
THIS WAS ORIGINALLY CALLED A
CHINA WUHAN VIRUS OR CHINESE
VIRUS.
THAT’S WHAT IT IS.
AND I THINK THAT IT’S A SAD
STORY THAT FOR OVER A YEAR THE
WESTERN WORLD WAS BASICALLY
LIED TO BY CHINA AND ACCEPTED
IT.
AND PEOPLE WHO SAID THIS IS A
LABORATORY WERE RIDICULED.
AND I THINK NOW YOU ARE
BEGINNING TO FIND OUT THE
WEIGHT OF EVIDENCE IS
OVERWHELMING IN PART BECAUSE
TECHNICALLY A DISEASE WHICH
COMES THROUGH AN ANIMAL INTO A
HUMAN EVOLVES AT A MUCH SLOWER
RATE.
THIS WAS A VERY RAPID I THINK
DELIBERATELY ENGINEERED DISEASE
PROBABLY ESCAPED BECAUSE OF
CLUMSINESS OR SLOPPINESS,
PROBABLY NOT A DELIBERATE
EFFORT BUT NONETHELESS CHINA IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE DEATH OF
MILLIONS AND ECONOMIC CRISIS
ACROSS THE PLANET.
DISRUPTING THE ENTIRE WORLD
SYSTEM AND THE CHINESE OUGHT TO
BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE.
>> Bill: I DON’T DISAGREE WITH
ANYTHING YOU’VE SAID.
I DON’T KNOW IF YOU’LL EVER GET
AN HONEST ANSWER OUT OF A
CHINESE COMMUNIST GOVERNMENT NO
MATTER THE EVIDENCE.
NOW YOU HAVE THIS 90 DAY PERIOD.
I DON’T KNOW WHAT YOU DO DURING
THAT AND COLLECT MORE EVIDENCE
AND PUT INTO A BIG REPORT THAT
MAKES IT OBVIOUS FOR THE WORLD
TO SEE AND PERHAPS YOU GO GET
YOUR ALLIES, JAPAN, SOUTH
KOREA, AUSTRALIA, NATO ALLIES
AND PUT UP A UNITED
INTERNATIONAL FRONT TO FORCE
BEIJING THE ADMIT IT.
EVEN THEN, THE CHINESE
COMMUNIST PARTY WILL NOT MAKE A
PUBLIC ADMISSION OF THIS SO
WHAT IS THE LEVEL OF PRESSURE
AT THAT POINT ON PRESIDENT XI?
GO AHEAD.
>> WHAT WE OUGHT TO DO I THINK
IS ESTABLISH A 30 OR 40% EXTRA
TARIFF ON ALL CHINESE GOODS.
PUT THAT MONEY INTO A FUND TO
PAY OFF THE FAMILIES.
ALLOW THE FAMILIES TO SUE JUST
LIKE YOU WOULD FOR ANY KIND OF
INDUSTRIAL PROBLEM.
WE HAVE ALL SEEN COMMERCIALS.
IF YOU EVER HAD X CALL THE LAW
FIRM.
WE OUT TO SAY WE’LL CHARGE THE
CHINESE AN EXTRA TARIFF FOR
BEING BAD ACTORS AND KEEP THE
TARIFF ON UNTIL WE RAISE ENOUGH
MONEY TO PAY OFF EVERY AMERICAN
FAMILY.
THE REST OF THE WORLD SHOULD
TAKE NOTE OF THAT AND DO THE
SAME THING.
XI WOULD BE FACING A REAL
PROBLEM BECAUSE HIS EXPORT
MACHINE THAT KEEPS HIS ECONOMY
ROLLING WOULD BE BREAKING.
AND HE WOULD HAVE A REAL
DOMESTIC PROBLEM NOT JUST A
BUNCH OF WORDS.
>> Bill: LAST POINT HOOR.
DAVID ASHER YESTERDAY AFTERNOON
WITH JOHN ROBERTS INTRIGUING
STUFF ON THE INTEL COMMUNITY.
GIVE IT A LISTEN.
>> I HAVE A LOT OF CONFIDENCE
IN THE INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY.
THEY WILL FIND LOT.
WHETHER THEY WILL SAY MUCH IS A
DIFFERENT MATTER.
WE MADE A BIG EFFORT UNDER
SECRETARY POMPEO’S LEADERSHIP
TO DECLASSIFY CRITICAL
INFORMATION.
I HOPE AND KNOW CONGRESS
ENDORSES THIS BIPARTISAN THAT
THIS ADMINISTRATION WILL DO THE
SAME.
WE NEED TO FIND OUT THE TRUTH
FOR THE SAKE OF OUR FUTURE AND
HUMANITY.
>> Bill: WHERE DO YOU SEE THAT
GOING, SIR?
>> WELL, THIS ADMINISTRATION
WANTS TO SOMEHOW FIND A WAY TO
BE CHINA’S FRIEND, NOT ENEMY.
I DOUBT VERY MUCH IF PRESIDENT
BIDEN IS GOING TO ALLOW THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE TO KNOW WHAT
THE AMERICAN INTELLIGENCE
COMMUNITY ALREADY KNOWS.
I WOULD BE VERY SURPRISED.
>> Bill: WOW.
I HOPE THAT’S NOT THE CASE.
SIR, THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.